good someone says well I'll tell all ah
go for that let's see
hi Jordan what are feelings and why do
we have them well here's a way of
thinking about it so look let's say you
were walking down the pathway I actually
saw this happen one day so I'll tell you
this story so I was walking along the
cliffs near I think it was San Diego
where la I don't remember I think it's
probably I think it was it I think it
was San Diego anyways I was walking
along there with some friends and and a
brother of a friend of mine who was
quite a tall guy is about six foot five
something like that and he was walking
along the path on the edge of the cliff
kind of sandy and with with scrub pine
around overlooking the Pacific Ocean and
it was March I think so was warm but not
too warm we were walking along and all
of a sudden his little girl who I think
was like four or five I saw she was
walking in front of him and in front of
me and I guess we were going around a
little bit of a corner and all of a
sudden she jumped right up on his
shoulders which I'd never seen a child
do that it was like watching you know if
you if a cat's sleep in you and you and
you go at it it'll like jump up and puff
out its hair and can jump straight up
well that's what this kid did and there
was a rattlesnake at the side of the of
the path now it was cold which was
probably good but you know there's a guy
named uh-oh
oh I carry who wrote a great book on
fear it'll come to me it'll come to me
it's a book that I should have on my
book list actually and he showed that
there are circuits in your brain there
reflex circuits so this had been
demonstrated to some degree much earlier
that map so imagine that a snake is a
pattern and then imagine that there's a
pattern on your retina that constitutes
the snake and then imagine that that can
be transformed into another pattern
which is a muscular output pattern and
that muscular output pattern is to jump
you in the air so your eyes make your
your make your muscles move in a
ticular way in and that happens before
you see the snake and before you're
afraid and the reason for that is that
so it's there are not many neural
connections between snake detection and
leaping in the air and that's because if
you waited to feel fear and waited to
see the snake that would take between a
quarter and half a second something like
that and the snake would have already
bitten you so unless you had those
really short neural pathways that have
been conserved in the evolutionary
process since like the beginning of time
anything super fast and simple would be
able to kill you so now so let's say
that you do encounter something
unexpected well first you have these
bodily reflexes that are really fast and
then the next thing that happens
generally speaking is that you feel an
emotion like maybe you're frozen so if
you hear a real growl behind you you'll
freeze and then you'll feel fear and
that'll keep you frozen and so the the
fear is a an indication of that
physiological state and then only after
that will you start to think and
strategize and so you need reactions at
multiple levels of temporal resolution
in order to keep you safe in the world
and the fast reactions are muscular and
reflexive and then the next ones
generally speaking or something like
emotions and they're low resolution but
quick you know like if you're afraid it
means there's something that may be
dangerous it's vague it's not till you
explore it that you know exactly what
the danger is but the fear is a good
enough initial category so you could
think about feelings as instinctual
categories things to love things to eat
things to run away from things to run
towards they're low resolution
categories and that's how animals
categorize the world they use emotion
and motivation to categorize the world
so we have them to keep ourselves
properly oriented in the world and to
react quickly and so that we can stay
alive